[Music]
how did the cobalt with three assists
what's up by to back your jet breathe
easy just the best player in the world
unselfish Jeffrey
see he comes away with the rebound
[Music]
my change chief Ben Wallace boarded up
the fans love the
James we send it to another assist for
LeBron Patterson
[Applause]
sizes up Belinelli attacks it they can't
stop him the audacity of LeBron James as
he continues to pile up boys like babies
got an early on island by himself LeBron
with the dance to the
[Applause]
okay the deep into play of the year how
about do it I'm gonna go right at your
chest
yeah put your arms up like it the power
[Applause]
[Music]
Bronte trip downtown timeout Golden
State coming into the game 18% from
three but tonight with
three of five from three not clapping
for you two a chance of triple-doubles
together
here's a chance he's got two tickets
[Applause]
yes it up I thought you did a great
forward before
no second
let's eat these things back in
James
[Applause]
they don't switch this out to us
see you back to his life
[Music]
boy 30
the tips here he's an outstanding
Chalmers
Marie helps out Smith pass right through
the hands of Carrie James but two-handed
slam unable to catch the basketball
James just sees the ribbon mama call of
clay habla Cola
don't talk big-time finish by James
what's up you guys it's tailored rooks
with bleacher report make sure you
subscribe for more video content